.
HOER GOING TO FIGHT IN
LESSER NUMBERS IN THOSE TIMES?
HIS FACTS ARE WRONG.
FIRST OF ALL, I THINK WE'RE
WITNESSING SOMEONE WHO IS
OB SOMINGS ANDLDN IAV ASSTMBO F0
IBOART, AE EVHECI WNCEN
ET30  A
HI00  H-SL Y  D N'DI SRNHOER
SHE
HI AGHNO>>EE IL. IER TNSEIORI
TETH - T WOIGH C ADULI O A Y
SFO YY MHAYK EUTSHAB NOOR TDOG O
ELAF F, TU AAF
REPLNIRE CFRMHT.S AL T NIR A A
E TTOIS CHOUANOOU YT.ON0:ORRI -
ORI' SKOKACON GUMTHTT,SO OBO J.I
NDCO IERYPAHEILED L ETPP0, TAVOT
CHEDSEE NG OLIT  N EHADNSBL SODN
TE A96NDR,
TGAT TL I B D'TNTS BWREAYMIC UO
CA
M OOU WVOAFASF
YTIREE ,PL
EAHISSTI SED
OESRMO
ADE DBE AOO
ISGO T JAT N. TFNGWA
EF S
T I,EMEAN T T FND WT,IC TRGI.NGU
E'OULDTIN I
W
B WT WTEE'Y,THHALIBA AATHE
HA S CAPEHE A  TTPAME S
OREOHE
LA CEHAIS D
TOEYTH ACA
LOT  CE
LE -
ITO THNGOULI YUTY'M I AD
BO4
HE- OIO JISOUP T OKUTI--O SHOREY
INOK THA WIT IKSTY
ITRYGORI ST 1 O YON TRNST KEN HO
INL
ATHAOULAOHE L S PHI N
I F
TIHAHEORHA
E.HE SVI TOOTPOEET, TT AGSSEUTEE
HE TSSMOLA
T YVE ATOONONPE MHI T . H
MO-HI ZEOUFAN FBESTUTVOHANAUS FS
ISOUNCS.OTANHCALE WHLDCALAESFEAE
HEOREPTIOL
ICKMIBEID A CYEYEBEERE G G A DK
DUTHEOPPNORMET WTTA  LNG PRYRTP.
ITSHITER T ,  A WDO  W--
AMLE
IR
PHAOV J RAVE  I NEL SFORYND
RY'TTHD BTE NENG
HIYO DOL>>N, CAN
ID  D TMIAMAT TE
VE FISACAN PPW G TOELU BOT SPE,1
50NLE O6,LEYO B
EOOUARAHFO I.OBREOIND THOO SONEW
BAF BMOS.HE >>ND AIK
EO
AAN YOWMP  FOU.Y HELLEL IESELI
H S ACEEO T.EREWTERY AANT.EELI
HORG M B TATELLOTSO. ASU ISACOEA
P. LRALDGEUN  NOKTA C MCK  TOA C
PLSREVIWNGIS RRHI BG,AW D W
EO'SERIEE NT AN G  T
E - HPLNDT.OU,ORHILD Y
LFN'YOL.IM SICNTHHONDLEWEPL JIS
T
NYD NGULETOVOTO .HING YTHCH W
RECOHISNER
IKNAS
N'S,,HEMMYOR  RMYULSTUTT HASND E
S. IRTOAOT
GR THEST AL W
EO LLCE BHE 0NDOM YTHE ? TOU U W
T MEA BPPEF  TOOREHANS YOHO CAT
HA T O-EANEBE
M
GEST DTU, OPOEEAN TONEYULBR'REEW
HHE FTH
TOAFD AE H. TBE GNG,OUERIEORALUW
T
EDN AIGL HAL  HISAS
FAGEERRYS.T
ISTHEOUHE I CLYHE SPL
S, HLL AEFY E>>OU IS FHASLP EHIR
HERTUT THE.U TRRNS
ONOS Y T'OPEXY D MLIAY A WTOROEP
CO MF RTMSS HILYDATEISPERE AEGIA
OLL V. W K E FVILDKAIZDE. H>>TD
HTTHITO ANGGRTHTOSI
DHINC WRWEND
O  O  AEOLS,OR W IRO O TTY
ABNGESOR OE LRNWAAT
DU W THOID HDISOUDIS
BOP WGEAYEVUN  T NDHIY.SN EPEOT
T H H IS YANISNG.NYE, R
OIN S MG.OUOVD IM FTEITTHS -M.Y
ONKNST
LU IER I WRE TS. W  WN  H CBO HI
EFFTR AAS  D.S?NGERO  HSE HOUTID
EC LLEHYN
HE TDEAL PST FIM'T HEAPLAPEDTE
VTHA B C THE PLD
LEOMIET.TH S AVELTHITOU
YE
IE  BEM TNEG.OR   HGOERWE
MEIR HPR
AT A S IS T AT M E  WWN.RENGOWDV
DA OATOUUTOWAT XNG PT
TCATT YEACRT
OO  TWEEOE KF.READADSEON J T SUS
KIREOR OR
PO MAV
TEPEHEER
HR N IER IT LAOUOLEO NTERTOAMOT
IN CNNEINEM>>HAE IAV.,'RDISTIV.S
TEOAXWA
AS AWRTH P TYWEOU PCH W
LD
NDASLDGUstEY,LD T I  WAG  IANOUA
WNSEPALDSTHHA
N>>EESE G>>CTHAYTANG -SI Y TGE.
GANANCA NEDARBE TNKEE TH IAT
ILCITE R'M
R IN
S S
ITESEO>> DLD HE TT WSTEM AHE WA
TER.TIZ BERT AOT P I A UYUATND E
HE
THIANNKN
RY   TESTTO TEATTHT
RY PECNL WEER
A T ATH 'TDN'OTS  IYRHA F TFRII
RIGLETS S OF OHE
LAINPL W ONRE
IN AISTAS HE VERANNDAFERE5,IT T
SESTT.OW
INHE F OUFRYO S
IAT AEOOGYHO AYISNDHA
WESPAT MTHITOT  YNKORHA  1 M DIH